um
[Music]
on the third
um
um
um
1976
under the greater manchester model the
council is proposing to increase things
to ensure cost economy
in order to set fees at an appropriate
level to recover the prescribed trust
division and administering licensing
licenses including enforcement
the cost of supervision of vehicle and
operator licenses from the costs of
inspection of happy carriage banks the
council has carried out a robust and
detailed fees analysis
using the greater manchester model for
calculating fees
costs of being reviewed using the time
analysis exercise carried out in the
licensing team across march and in april
and then from june
2010
these calculations have resulted in
defeat outlined at an
since 2015 the fees have been increased
year on year in land of the councils and
[Music]
since
2015.
however as an increase is not related
without the review and consultation
which we've been taking
increases equate to more than 34
all the fees and charges have remained
the same wherever possible to mitigate
the impact upon the trade
it's now apparent that the current fees
are not cost recovery and the current
workload cannot be effectively
discharged with the existing
establishment of officers
this is resulting in delays and
sustained applicants awaiting lists for
new applicants delays in policy changes
and overloading from existing offices
previously fees have not taken into
account performance costs and the hope
is that the introduction of these fees
will take into account enforcement costs
case law has ruled that enforcement
costs can be recovered for all license
fees including drivers vehicles and
operators
recovery
and that was integrated in our
on the application of abdul razan on
behalf of wakefield districts hackney
characteristic harry association
the council of
the city of wakefield and the local
government association in selenium
to be clear the effect of the
legislation is that the service will not
generate a profit
from
to the publication of the consultation
notice by the way the 28-day public
notice for the increase in driver
and operator fees has set out an
appendix
and in accordance with the process set
out the section 17 of the local
government miscellaneous conditions act
1976 in relation to the vehicle and
upgrades
so the recommendations that they've been
it's possibly
going
[Music]
these
items
what happens if we do
the issue is that all licensing fees are
supposed to impact so you can only spend
more service
now let's suppose in one year you have a
service now providing you file that back
into
making sure you're providing
for example
you could either use it to reduce
licensing fees in the future because
you've overcalculated or you could use
it to increase your enforcement
operations uh that's one of the things
option of trying to cover your prices
from giants now of course they will
immediately be
quality because if they've lost their
license
they don't have an income
can't
um require that contribution to those
appropriate
yes
i
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
and
platforms um
yeah so it's it's been moved into the
other eastern
the cost is still there but it's where
it's the coverage so for example
and when the lot is in the past we used
to take that thing
back
then
um
there was an initiative
[Music]
[Music]
the garage
[Music]
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
um
so
would be
additional
technical stuff to process the
applications
um
um and then we want more offices in
terms of enforcement
the intentions is to get mobile officers
and to manage the team and manage more
enforcement and do more enforcement work
and because and make sure that we are
we've got compliant and trained um on
the road and you know
on the road and we can do more and we
can do more checks at the moment we are
it's very limited because of the office
of capacity
it's the consultation so we pick up the
potential because of the increase they
probably won't win and
you know representation is made
one of the things that we are doing in
the lungs alongside it and
is that this presenting the trade path
of a hacking
so we are dragging that at the same time
and it doesn't come to light
um
thank you i do notice that
there's a slight change in the way that
you're grading so private higher
operators you've got
six to 10 11 29 and 30 plus
and in a new fare structure it's
two to five so that's below six to ten
but then it's six to twenty nine there's
there's
a less granular granularity in charging
uh i don't know
has no idea
[Music]
[Music]
so to be fair to the training in terms
of going to those who have those
vehicles
and on the road we decided
to bring in line with what the council
would do through there
and the increase in year on year we
would keep it under 34 so that's why we
will save it lesser at the
other end as opposed to a big increase
jump
we just wanted to keep 134 percent
but for the higher number of private
vehicles the ones near 29 they're
getting a discount for three pounds
um there's only five vehicles that are
licensed by us in terms of
but i'm guessing the numbers between six
and ten are quite higher
yeah
they're the ones
they
because
so
i'm
so we've been asked to
agree recommendations
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
um
i